about the candy it sounds good it's a
combination of
granulated sugar coconut peanut butter
it is a stick
i don't know why you just didn't tell us
about it sounds fantastic i'm going to
try a chicken stick
this weekend we are nearly halfway
through the nfl season ron futrell joins
us now with a
mid-season update and a preview of the
raiders browns game on sunday
so here we go week 8 of the nfl season
the bettors have been doing okay the
sports books are still around certainly
and the folks at bet mgm have enlisted
actor
jamie foxx to promote their new app and
step three
showtime td's back with k's
rbis and the tko's they beat
to get jamie foxx to do something for us
is unbelievable the commercials are very
well produced they are
spectacular commercials so we've got a
lot of feedback and it's brought a lot
of publicity to
bet mgm so to get somebody from jamie
foxx was a big coup for us
and then we have the raiders at the
cleveland browns on sunday a matchup of
two of the worst defenses in the league
yeah it's going to be a high scoring
game here cleveland's got the 30th
worst pass offense so hopefully derrick
carr can take advantage of that
the bettors are believing in the raiders
so the raiders have their work cut out
for themselves
at cleveland on sunday but allegiant
stadium is not going to be quiet this
weekend of course the rebels have a
football game against the wolfpack
on saturday for the first time fans will
be allowed into the stadium
at allegion stadium ron futuro reporting
eight sports now